unser land umfassend zu verteidigen und
unsere unabhängigkeit und neutralität zu
schützen das ist das oberste ziel des
österreichischen bundesheeres
doch welche aufgaben hat das bundesheer
konkret seine wichtigste aufgabe ist die
militärische landesverteidigung die
soldatinnen und soldaten sind dazu im
ständigen training um im ernstfall
sofort und bestmöglich einsatzbereit zu
sein
das bundesheer übernimmt aber auch
zahlreiche assistenzeinsätze im inneren
dazu zählt beispielsweise die
überwachung der grenzen sowie der schutz
wichtiger staatlicher einrichtungen oder
die bewachung von botschaften
eine weitere wichtige aufgabe sind
hilfseinsätze bei katastrophen
denn mit seiner besonderen organisation
geschaffen für extremsituationen und der
speziellen ausrüstung kann das
bundesheer hier rasch und effizient
hilfe leisten
zusätzlich nehmen aktuell 1000
österreichische soldatinnen und soldaten
an einsätzen im ausland teil
aus solidarität zur internationalen
gemeinschaft und zur stärkung der
weltweiten sicherheit
denn der schutz österreichs beginnt
bereits vor den grenzen unseres landes
das österreichische bundesheer ein heer
von möglichkeiten mit sicherheit für uns
alle